The Joe Rogan experience.
I've been listening to radio
lab on the way over here and um,
they have a new episode out about the
asteroid impact that killed the dinosaurs.
Yeah. Holy Shit Man. Right.
Would you apparently they tell me if
I'm right about this before you tell me
more because I want to see if I
have a little knowledge. Go ahead.
There is an under,
like there's a very hard layer of rock
that covers a large part of the earth.
Right.
And that is proof that somehow there was
an asteroid that hit and it got really,
really hot and the Rock God,
the morons version of a size that they
clearly lay out by the way is the worst
thing. I'm also like, there's
a rock that got melted day.
This was under the ground,
undeniable evidence of a rock of from
this space as every layer of the earth.
The crust of the earth is
super hard because it got
really hot after an asteroid
hitting. Everybody died and they found
dinosaur bones in it. Yeah Bro. They can.
They can don't believe
in dinosaurs cause I'm,
you know I have something
called the Bible at home,
but some people don't
believe in dinosaurs.
Do you know that this flat earth folks,
while those dinosaurs are fake,
why is it that most flat earthers from
my experience are generally super good at
like a discipline that has nothing to
do with astrophysics, like Jujitsu,
like they spent a lot of time on a mat,
but then they have really strong political
opinions about that. Central banks,
it think it's just a lack of
real education and then yeah,
you get caught up in these youtube things
that show you a secret and it's very
attractive. It's very attractive to look,
find out about some hidden stuff like,
oh my God, I can't believe they
did this. They hid from us.
The fact that the earth is flat.
Jesus Christ spaces fake too.
Pro Space is fake. Satellites aren't
real. They're low flying planes,
their planes there.
That's the constantly beaming down
these information from the sky.
Satellites are not real nuclear
bombs and not real. Yeah.
Not really just big bombs,
but then the problem is when you break
your leg and you have to set your bone or
you get staff and, and you have
to trust big Pharma to cure it.
Or you use your iPhone and it works
and you're talking to somebody in debt,
big one. You know what
I'm saying? So, but why?
Why is that technology
something you trust?
Your fucking iPhone has a global
positioning satellite chip and it stopped
porous.
It links up with the fucking one that's
in the sky and it tells you where you
are on the map. That's why your Google
maps works. Jesus fucking Christ.
These are probably only five or six
flat earthers. No, there's a lot. Yeah,
there's thousands of them. Well, okay,
but that really means only
five or six in the ground.
I think the problem with all of them is
that they just got married to the idea
and then they're fighting it.
And if you fight it with someone who
doesn't know what they're talking about,
not that I do know what I'm talking about,
but if you fight it with like a Sean
Carroll or like a real assets is a real
scientific study,
they,
there's so much evidence that the earth
is round and no evidence that the earth
is flat. It's one of those things where
it's just like, what are you guys doing?
You're chasing your tail.
Yeah. This is crazy. Too busy.
Way Too busy or youtube.
Okay.